This next story is one of the funniest things
that has ever happened on this show.
Uh, I believe that I have caught extremist
right winger and proud boy, founder Gavin
McInnes calling into the show, pretending
to be someone else in order to promote his
new program.
Last week, I got a call during live calls
from a guy who said, hey, my name is Jim David.
Have you heard about Gavin McInnes his new
show?
He interviews left wingers, you should go
on his show.
You should own him.
And I didn't really think much of it.
Uh, the caller said he had a subscription
to Gavin McInnes his show.
And then after watching all of the videos,
he canceled it.
And because I'm in the media space and I've
heard of Gavin McInnes his new show, it didn't
sound obviously weird to me, but after the
fact, I started thinking, you know, the truth
is nobody's really heard of Gavin McInnes
his new show, especially people on the left.
It is sort of weird to imagine that a left
winger is going to go and pay for a subscription
to Gavin McInnes show.
And over the weekend, a bunch of people on
our subreddit started posting that, Hey David,
that sounded a lot like Gavin himself, who
called you a sort of mild Canadian accent?
That was Gavin and is David playing along
or is David not realizing it?
So I sent it over to my manager, Oh, who knows
about this show?
And he said, yeah, it does sound a lot like
Gavin McInnes.
I've gone back and listened to the call again
and I believe that this is Gavin McInnes and
this is hilarious for a few different reasons,
but first let's listen to part of the call
just so everybody knows what I'm talking about.
Okay, let's go next to Hower color from the
two five, three area code.
Who's calling today from two five three.
Okay.
Hey David, it's a gym and I just wanted to
say a longtime listener first time.
Love Ya.
And I just wanted to talk about the green
new deal and just see what ideas you had about
maybe getting that pushed through.
And also, um, a guy I despise came up on my
youtube the other day on a commercial Gavin
McInnes on this new show free speech.
And I was trying to click out of it right
away and then all of a sudden I saw Dr Cornell
West and Mark Lamont Hill on the show.
Yeah.
And I actually checked it out and um, it's
a cool show in regards to just liberals Nailing
Gavin.
And it was so awesome to watch, especially
Marc Lamont Hill.
I canceled my subscription because I saw all
the shows, but I just thought it'd be awesome
if you could get on his show and destroy him.
So hold on.
You said you canceled your subscription to
what?
Oh, I signed up just to wash the doctor Lamont
Hill.
Oh, I see.
I see the Cornell.
So on the speech,
so clearly the caller is someone who's very
comfortable on calls like this.
That's not really evidenced that it's Gavin
McInnes.
He does seem to know a little bit too much
about Gavin McInnes, his new show, despite
the fact that like no leftist has even mentioned
this program to me ever.
And no leftist really seems to be aware of
this program.
He claims that he subscribed to it just to
see an interview with Mark Lamont Hill, which
is sort of hard to believe that that's what
somebody would do.
And then I went and listened to other interviews
with Gavin and it sounds like this is Gavin
McInnes.
There's a slight Canadian accent when you
listen to the pronunciation of some words,
the Real Gavin is Canadian.
I actually was able to get in touch with former
personal friends of Gavin McInnes his and
said, just tell me what you think is the color
Gavin.
They all said, I've had many phone conversations
with Gavin 99.9%.
That is Gavin McInnes.
Uh, the name Jim that was used matches another
data point that I was able to find related
to people associated with Gavin McInnes.
Uh, I don't know how else to kind of say that
part.
We also backtrack the phone number that this
individual called from the phone number again
matches a known location for where Gavin McInnes
lived for a long time.
So basically I, I believe there is a 99.9%
chance that Gavin McInnes is personally calling
other programs and um, uh, under the name
Jim reminds me of what was Trump's a fake
guy.
Daniel Miller or said to Trump, had some name
he used to call a what?
When, when he would call other places about
himself.
And there's a few takeaways.
Number one, Gavin McInnes truly seems so desperate
to get attention for his show that he's sitting
around calling shows like mine when I opened
the phone lines to mention his own show.
That's pathetic.
Now.
Second, why not have someone else call?
Like it would be hilarious if a hundred people
from my audience started calling conservative
shows and mentioning the David Pakman show,
that would actually be really funny.
It would annoy the right wing hosts.
I would get those clips, I would play them,
but me just calling a show and mentioning
my own name, that's a lot less funny and interesting.
But it also goes to show because I'm totally
clueless and I wouldn't even recognize Gavin's
voice.
I actually thought maybe there is some left
winger in my audience who actually signed
up and paid for Gavin McInnes his show to
watch Marc Lamont Hill, which upon any amount
of inspection doesn't sound right at all.
Now here's the situation that's going on behind
the scenes.
This is not random.
What's going on behind the scenes is that
Gavin McInnes his program, I don't know where
they get the money, but they are offering
to pay guests to come on.
Now this is not typically done.
We have never paid a guest.
We've had what, 1500 interviews that have
done.
We've had like two or three people ask for
money.
Oh, we've never paid.
We just never pay for guests.
Every time I appear on CNN, Fox News, I'm
never paid for those appearances.
Okay.
Uh, the Gavin McInnes program is apparently
so desperate to get people to appear on this
program that they reached out to me through
my manager and offered, I'm not going to say
how much, but a lot of money for me to appear
on the program.
So what took place here was not random promotion.
What appears that happened is that knowing
that there is a conversation taking place
with my manager about will David pacman appeared
with Gavin McInnes.
Gavin thought, hey, here's an idea.
I'll call David as Jim and pretend to be a
leftist who really wants to see David appear
on Gavin McInnes his show.
This is absolutely nuts that this is going
on.
There are other progressive hosts who I won't
name because I don't know if they're going
public with it, who have also been approached
by this program and offered money to appear.
Uh, and my manager had the hilarious idea
of if the number isn't spoofed, like if I
could actually call the number back and, and
speak to Gavin, say, Hey Jim, you called me
on the David Pakman show.
I just wanted to tell you, uh, I, I actually
am thinking of appearing on that show.
Just kidding.
Gavin.
This is you, right?
Why'd you call me?
Why'd you call me live on the air?
Let me know what you think.
Absolutely stunning, bizarre and outrageous
that this is what's going on.
Uh, but this is where things are apparently
for Gavin McInnes.
At this point in time,